the United States Post Office expects to
deliver more than 900 million packages
this holiday season but some criminals
have found a new way to try and steal
your mail well these are so-called porch
pirates and they're taking advantage of
a digital notification system from the
Postal Service it gives an early look at
what's coming in the mail chip Reid is
at a post office in Washington DC with
the best way to protect yourself
chip good morning Wow have the times
changed you sure have you know the US
Postal Service took a leap into the
digital age last year with a service
called informed delivery if you sign up
they will send you a preview by email
every day of what's coming in the real
mail later that day but now privacy
advocates have a warning you've got mail
that's the message each morning in the
email inbox of 13 million people who
signed up with the post office for
informed delivery wherever you are an
email arrives with a scan of any mail on
its way that day so you can be sitting
in the coffee shop in the morning on
your phone and see what mail you're
gonna be getting later that day Bob
Dixon developed informed delivery for
the Postal Service
he says it's free and easy to sign up
create account and you're done in how
many minutes the last time we timed a
tester it took two and a half minutes
the post office asks people to verify
their identity with questions like past
cities and streets where they've lived
and the sale price of their home the
information could be on the dark web
it's being collected by companies that
collect and sell data this kind of
information is also oftentimes available
on social media that can allow scammers
to sign up with your name and address
but their email and now the Secret
Service warns criminals can take
advantage of informed delivery to
intercept mail and to further their
identity theft fraud schemes it enables
a fraudster to commit the fraud Krista
raka who had his identity stolen in a
2015 database breach says a scammer used
that
hacked data to sign up for informed
delivery in his name and swipe a credit
card from his mail someone was receiving
images and was monitoring
I guess the neighborhood and when they
saw that the credit card came in the
mail they then proceeded to follow the
postal delivery person the Postal
Service says households can opt out
online from informed delivery and warns
their inspectors are watching inform
delivery is a criminals worst nightmare
because we are continually monitoring
for any suspicious behavior
anyone who misuses our products we're
gonna detect that we're gonna shut down
the accounts and we're gonna conduct an
investigation to bring that criminal to
justice the Postal Service stresses that
the actual informed delivery database
has never been hacked they also say the
best way to protect yourself just might
be to sign up using your own email so
someone else can't sign up as you Gail
okay you got options thank you very much
tip